hi
uh i've been making
around about a dozen films now quite
close to it
and uh would like to
self-promote myself and
say if you're interested in what i'm
saying
there's a my book here
that is available in amazon uk
and i think i think around the world not
just for sure
but i'm pretty sure you can get them on
amazon
and also on ebay
i've written two books now i'm dyslexic
and i have terrible trouble
writing but with a very good friend of
mine
this is my second book and uh and this
book
keeping the mind of a child
to me compliments the first book the
first book tells you about
how i got into aikido
it it's the only book i believe in the
world
that's been critical enough to talk
about
the weaknesses within the techniques
it doesn't matter what style you do i've
send
dozens and dozens of styles dozens and
teachers and if i say to you
ekio you you'll all know what an ikea is
if i say inikyo
you'll all know what it is
you see these are words of techniques
and the technique pretty much is the
same
whether it's done in iwama
the homu dojo anywhere
in the world these techniques are pretty
standard
but they have flaws in them some of the
flaws are due to
the human being doing the technique
and they don't see the the gaps and the
problems and the angles
and so the first book i've taken the
trouble to take the most popular
techniques
and just to explain where the weaknesses
are
and to give you my opinion of
how to strengthen that technique
if your uk is flowing and blending with
you
that's not a real attack they're having
fun enjoying aikido and you're having
fun
doing aikido
but the technique may or may not work
out there in the street
where it is called a martial art and
we should consider that a lot of people
they say oh i don't do aikido for that i
do it for the spiritual side
these people are usually very gentle
people
lovely people to meet and to talk to but
they're not doing those senses art
but since his art was a very rigorous
training hard training
when i trained in iwama i couldn't
believe how hard the
tatami was i've never trained on such a
hard floor before
i thought that concrete may even be
softer
and these people trained there for years
and years on this
powerfully firm japanese traditional
tatami
absolutely no give whatsoever
no wonder there's so many japanese with
broken bodies now
these masters are teaching but when they
take their ghee off and that you see
them all strapped up all
in a bad way so the first book
i believe is the first one to point out
the weakness in other styles
and the things that i've come to learn
that were important
and i've tried to put those senses
understanding into
why i'm explaining the techniques the
way i do
if you held if i was holding here a
piece of string
from end to end
then it would be continuous pretty
obvious isn't it
the problem is when we do
that psychotic ice and we throw okay
the moment from applying the pressure
on the wrist
and then taking off and going through
the air there's a moment in time
where narcan doesn't quite catch up with
luka there's a small space
and most of you who would have been
having fun with another
partner of yours either after class
while class was on doing code glaciers
you may have come across the uk who
decides that they're
really good at ukemi and they're faster
than you
and before you've got to the pin
they're up looking at you smiling
they've outspeeded you it's because
the string wasn't continuous
so in this first book i've taken the
trouble to try to show you that you go
from the hand and you slide down the
forearm
and you have to do this while they're in
the air and you have to be 100
with them
there's a person i respect greatly
eckhart tolle he's written quite he's
written some books now
and some cds you can listen to him
he says one of the books the power of
now
being in the moment being in that
positive
millisecond so there's no gap
the string is not slack at all there's
no
dip it's a taut string that's how you
and your partner has to be
from the moment they arrive in front of
you
to the moment you decide it needs to end
in a code guys that would be
by pinning them on the floor either you
in a standing pin
or kneeling pin only you release them
they cannot outspeed you because you're
with them
so there's no such thing as outspeeding
you if they're doing
50 then you're doing 50 if they're doing
80 you're doing 80.
so that's the first book
so i hope perhaps you'll purchase it
it's not on kindle i'm afraid that one
it's only hard back
my second book i tried to talk about the
spiritual side of my life
and all the suggestions that i can help
by passing on to yourself on how to
become a better person
what you have what in my opinion you
have to do
how you how you look at yourself
there's one that jumps to mind i call it
the driver in front
how many of you are driving
a vehicle complaining about the person
in front of you on the motorway how bad
their driving is
why don't they get over it could be on a
small street
can they hear you the driving front no
so why bother to do it does it make you
feel any better
not usually it normally makes you even
wilder
until you come across across the next
person driving
not to your liking
life's full of these happenings but the
driver in front
is one that i think most of
the the world appears to
be in common with and you say you'll
know what i mean
if you was on a side road where you
could perhaps
pull up behind them or pull up alongside
them
and tell tell them about their driving
most people wouldn't do this anyhow so
why do it sitting in your car wouldn't
there be better things to think about
you know think about going on holiday
think about your aikido techniques think
about anything that's important to you
to me this is becoming a better person
not wasting your time on things that
they can't hear
you know you are the driver in front of
somebody else
and they're saying and thinking the same
things about you
or do you think you're the perfect
driver the same as the
the perfect kodagash practitioner
please think hard about these thoughts
because i think you'll find that we all
have the same problems
and my second book goes into meditation
yoga tai chi
aikido and life and it gives you
many many ways of
looking at it i have several people who
have written to me saying
they're gonna have to read it again
because it so
speaks about themself and the way
they look at life and one person say
oh dear i hope it's not too late to
start changing
i've been the person that you're talking
about and you were so brave to say the
things you did
because most people wouldn't want things
to be said like that
so there's my promotion for my books but
i hope my words
have run true to how you would think and
not just to buy my books
for that reason i'm hoping you will find
benefit by them
and it will allow you to grow more ins
as a spiritual path because you are the
spiritual path
you don't have to become a buddhist monk
to walk a spiritual path
you just have to become a better person
by becoming better person
you'll become a better aikidoka you will
see the gaps
and you will become more precise
i hope you've enjoyed this section
and again please like it
or subscribe if you'd like to
hear more of my thoughts and continue
with me on this journey thank you